hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream bei uns geht es heute um das hier
um Flucht statt Kampfeinsatz da haben
wir es eingeblendet denn 10.000
russische Männer sie versuchen gerade
aus ihrer Heimat zu fliehen sie
versuchen zu fliehen vor der
Teilmobilmachung von russlands Präsident
Vladimir Putin sie wollen eben nicht für
die russische Armee im Krieg in der
Ukraine antreten und für viele ist dabei
das Ziel die EU oder auch Deutschland
wir haben vorhin mit einem gesprochen
der aktuell in Berlin Wald und wir
diskutieren natürlich heute auch die
Frage die sich politisch stellt wie
sollte Deutschland mit russischen
Kriegsdienst Verweigerern und
Deserteuren umgehen ihr könnt natürlich
mitdiskutieren Teil der Sendung sein ihr
kennt das alle Fragen oder Kommentare
einfach direkt in die Chats oder an die
Mailadresse die jetzt eingeblendet wird
erstmal schauen wir uns an wie ist aber
die Situation aktuell an den Grenzen und
wie geht Europa generell mit der
Situation der geflüchteten um das zeigen
uns Antoine kuscheln und Carsten heckes
Stau an der finnischen Grenze 10.000
Russen versuchen vor einer Woche vor
Putins mobil machen zu fliehen
inzwischen ist die Grenze dicht immer
mehr Länder in Europa wie Finnland
Norwegen das Baltikum und Polen
schließen ihre Grenzen damit wird die
Flucht immer schwieriger sie ist nur
noch Richtung Kaukasus und Zentralasien
möglich oder wer es sich leisten kann
per Fliegern nach Serbien und in die
Türkei klare Worte dazu von der
litauischen Premierministerin
ich könnte kaum verstehen dass wir jetzt
Menschen aus humanitären Gründen nach
Litauen einreisen lassen wenn der Krieg
für Sie in Ordnung war als sie ihn nur
vom Sofa aus im Fernsehen gesehen haben
ob russische Kriegsdienst Verweigerer
einen rechtlichen Anspruch auf Asyl in
Deutschland haben hängt von mehreren
Faktoren ab grundsätzlich gilt das
Völkerrecht erlaubt es Ländern Bürger
für den Kriegsdienst einzuziehen
Kriegsdienst Verweigerer haben also nur
ein asylanspruch wenn sie Teilnahme an
Kriegsverbrechen gezwungen werden würden
oder wenn die Strafen für eine
Verweigerung unverhältnismäßig hoch
wären die Bundesregierung könnte auch
ein sonderaufnahmeprogramm einführen
das bedeutet dass also wie gesagt
Asylverfahren das von schweren
Repressionen bedrohte Deserteure in
Deutschland im Regelfall internationalen
Schutz Flüchtlingsschutz erhalten
darüber würde er sich sehr freuen die
Mitri konnte noch rechtzeitig fliehen
über Finnland und die Türkei landete er
in Armenien die Zustände in Russland
sein katastrophal berichtet der
Theaterregisseur
Industrie alle Menschen die der
Kreativindustrie angehören und die ich
kenne die ein Gewissen und Überzeugungen
haben sind aus Russland geflohen
Menschen werden überall festgehalten die
Türen ihrer Häuser versiegelt das sind
sehr unangenehme Gefühle
auch deshalb will Dimitri unbedingt nach
Deutschland er würde gerne in Berlin ein
neues Leben beginnen
ja das ist nicht nur das Ziel von
Dimitri wie gerade gesehen im Beitrag
sondern auch von vielen die gerade
flüchten das wirft natürlich aber auch
hier in Deutschland die Frage auf wer
genau sind diese Menschen die da aus
Russland zu uns kommen wollen sind Sie
wirklich Putin kritisch stellen sie sich
wirklich gegen den Krieg oder sind sie
jetzt nicht doch Leute das ist die Frage
die Putin lange unterstützt haben die
womöglich ihn auch jetzt noch
unterstützen diese Fragen und Sorgen die
haben natürlich auch vor allem die
Menschen die seit Ende Februar aus der
Ukraine nach Deutschland geflüchtet sind
das hat uns heute auch der ukrainische
Botschafter André Melnik noch einmal im
Gespräch bestätigt und uns das auch
erklärt
also wir glauben dass die Menschen die
ja noch in Russland geblieben sind denn
die
oppositionellen und NGO Leute kritische
Journalisten die sind schon längst weg
aus Russland geflohen noch
am Beginn dieses Krieges und deswegen
glauben wir schon dass diese Menschen
die jetzt sich gegen den stellen dass
sie lieber auch zu Hause bleiben und
gegen das Regime von Putin protestieren
auf die Straßen gehen denn wenn sie alle
weg sind dann ist die Hoffnung und viele
haben immer noch hier diese Hoffnung in
Deutschland auf einen regime change in
in Russland dann sind diese Hoffnungen
vergeblich weil da bleiben ja halt nur
diejenige die blind Putin folgen und das
ist doch nicht das was wir alle wollen
nämlich dass auch in Russland eine ein
Wandel
geben sollte eine demokratischen Wandel
denn wenn das nicht geschieht egal wie
der Krieg zu Ende geht wird es leider
aus unserer Sicht keinen langfristigen
Frieden auf dem europäischen Kontinenten
geben
soweit also andere Melnik noch sieben
Tage ist der ukrainischer Botschafter in
Deutschland den oton haben wir vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet und das
ausführliche Interview mit ihm gibt es
auch in der ZDF heute App oder auf ZDF
heute.de sprechen wir jetzt nicht weiter
über die Menschen die gerade aus
Russland fliehen wollen sondern
zumindest mit einem von ihnen was geht
in ihm vor was sagt er über die Menschen
die sich da gerade bewegen auch mit ihm
konnten wir vor der Sendung sprechen
sie sind 48 Jahre alt sind gebürtig aus
Moskau waren bis zu ihrer Flucht
Architekt in Russland haben zwei Kinder
im Teenageralter und sind jetzt mit
einem Schengen Visum in Berlin bei einem
Freund untergebracht an welchem Punkt
haben sie für sich beschlossen dass sie
ihr Land Russland verlassen müssen und
warum
entschieden etwa drei Tage vor meiner
Abreise
seit Februar
haben wir uns ähnliche Gedanken gemacht
meine Frau und ich haben uns so etwas
gedacht
aber damals hatten wir diese Möglichkeit
einfach nicht
Ende September wurde klar
ist
und die ganze Familie konnte das Land
nicht verlassen also ich bin dann als
erstes
losgefahren
und ich hoffe dass wir uns irgendwann
mal treffen vielleicht in einem anderen
Land
es wird es fällt mir schwer etwas zu
sagen vielleicht kehre ich nach Russland
zurück es fällt mir schwer zu sagen wie
es kommt
sie haben es gerade angesprochen dass
die Entscheidung für sie Ende September
gefallen ist dort hat Präsident Putin
die Teilmobilmachung angekündigt die
Einberufung vielleicht auch für Menschen
wie sie in die Armee war das der
endgültige Punkt für sie zu sagen das
kann ich nicht mehr
ja natürlich
gerade zu diesem Zeitpunkt fehlt diese
Entscheidung aber ich habe mir diese
Gedanken auch nach dem 24 Februar
gemacht
seit Ende Februar alles was damals los
war das kann man gar nicht
nachvollziehen das ist einfach unmöglich
einfach unerträglich
wie genau sind sie nach dieser
Entscheidung jetzt nach Deutschland
gekommen und sie haben es gerade schon
thematisiert sie haben ihre Familie
zurückgelassen sie sagen gerade das ist
unbeschreiblich die Gefühle zum Ausdruck
zu bringen aber vielleicht können Sie
das versuchen mit welchen Gefühlen sie
nach Deutschland gekommen sind was sie
da begleitet hat
ein gutes Kaiser ich kann gut ich kann
folgendes erzählen als ich Moskau
verließ
diese Entscheidung wurde eigentlich zwei
Tage vor der Abreise gefällt wir haben
darüber lange diskutiert und wir konnten
keine endgültige Entscheidung treffen
und ich dachte zunächst ich würde das
Land nicht verlassen ich hatte
verschiedene Zweifeln zu jedem Zeitpunkt
aber sich lohnt das Land zu verlassen
oder doch nicht und dann habe ich mich
doch für die Ausreise entschieden
ich weiß es nicht mehr wann das der Fall
war ich habe einfach ich bin einfach in
den zugestiegen das war am letzten
Mittwoch und ich bin dann bis St
Petersburg Gefahren mein Nachbar
im Zug war ein freiwilliger
in der russischen Armee und er erzählte
mir ganz schlimme Sachen obwohl ich ihm
keine Fragen gestellt habe
dann habe ich den Bus in St Petersburg
genommen und bin dann
Richtung Helsinki gefahren
und es hat sich herausgestellt dass das
der allerletzte Tag war wo die Grenze zu
Finnland offen war
und man konnte dann noch mit
touristischen Visa das Land verlassen
so dass es das war der Stand der Dinge
und wie ging es dann konkret weiter für
Sie nach Deutschland
in einem Hotel in Helsinki übernachtet
und bin dann nach Berlin zu meinen
Freunden geflogen
sie haben gerade eine Begegnung mit
einem russischen freiwilligen im Zug
angesprochen haben gesagt dass er ihnen
schlimme Dinge erzählt hat was waren das
für Dinge
ich hatte das Gefühl
dass die ist nicht seine Gedanken waren
er erzählte zum Beispiel
in der ukrainischen Armee
Söldner zu finden sind
nicht in der
Armee kämpfen also das nur sollten dann
dort vorzufinden sind
ich kann an so etwas unter keinen
Umständen glauben
und dann
erzählte er
wie ein Panzer in die Luft hochging wie
ein Flugzeug
in die Luft gehen und so weiter
denkt dass er an der Front wahre Männer
kennenlernen konnte er beschrieb das als
eine gewisse Brüderschaft
das hat mir eine gewisse Angst gemacht
ich bin an und für sich für den Frieden
und alle Gespräche über den Krieg vor
allem unter solchen Bedingungen
das kann ich nur schwer ertragen
sind denn die überwiegende Anzahl der
Menschen die sich auf den Weg gemacht
haben gegen Putin oder sind es Menschen
die ihn eigentlich noch immer
unterstützen aber jetzt einfach nur
nicht selbst in den Krieg gehen wollen
das sind
Ängste Sorgen die sich Leute hier in
Deutschland machen
falls die Gruppe die stärkste ist
ich glaube es gibt doch mehr Menschen
die sich gegen den Krieg aussprechen
aber es gibt natürlich auch Menschen die
Angst vor der Mobilisierung haben
für mich stellte sich die Frage
dass ich eventuell in Russland bleibe
und dann mobilisiert werde dann würde
ich
dann würde ich im Gefängnis landen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
zu kämpfen
geschweige denn ging Ukraine
oder wir haben hier vor wenigen Wochen
auch mit einem zum Beispiel russischen
Lokalpolitiker gesprochen der damals
eine Petition zur Absetzung Putins an
die Duma geschickt hat und sich damit
auch öffentlich im Land gegen Putin
gestellt hat sie haben gesagt dass sie
sich auch die Frage der Flucht oder der
Positionierung natürlich gegen den Krieg
und gegen Putin seid Ende Februar
gemacht haben haben sie sich auch
politisch im Land engagiert und wäre das
wenn sie zurückkehren sollten eine
Option
das ist eine komplexe Frage
und das möglich war und am 24 Februar
war ich am Puschkinplatz
damals gab es nicht so viele
Demonstrationsteilnehmer
und ich konnte damals auch verstehen
das ist eher
[Musik]
fallen wird etwas zu ändern wenn nur so
wenige Menschen auf die Straße gehen
das ist ein schwieriger Gedanke
man fühlt sich machtlos und
ich hatte bestimmte Möglichkeiten ich
habe aber zum Beispiel
am Flugblätter verteilt also das ist
alles was ich damals beitragen konnte
ich habe auch auf Facebook Beiträge
verfasst
ich kann nicht behaupten
dass meine Haltung sehr aktiv war
aber ich war immer dagegen
sie haben es jetzt gerade angesprochen
genau aus diesen Gründen haben sie die
Flucht ergriffen haben aber auch gesagt
dass sie aktuell ihre Familie hinter
sich gelassen haben dass sie die nur per
Skype oder auch SMS kontaktieren können
was sind denn ihre Pläne für die Zukunft
ist eine Rückkehr für Sie nach Russland
vorstellbar unter Putin oder was haben
sie für Pläne weil sie sind ja aktuell
nur mit einem begrenzten Schengenvisum
hier
[Musik]
eventuell in einem Drittland treffen
vielleicht treff vielleicht kehre ich
doch nach Russland zurück es liegt daran
was noch kommt was auf der Welt passiert
aber natürlich vor allem was in Russland
passiert was in der russischen Politik
passiert
sagt fior 48 Jahre geflüchtet aus Moskau
aktuell in Berlin vielen Dank für das
Gespräch
vielen Dank
also eine ungewisse Situation für förder
der hier bei ZDF heute live seine
Geschichte seine Flucht aus Moskau über
St Petersburg jetzt bis nach Berlin
geschildert hat eine ungewisse Situation
ein Einzelfall aus der sich natürlich
eine übergeordnete politische Frage
ergibt sollte Deutschland diesen
russischen Kriegsdienst Verweigerern und
der Saturn politisches Asyl gewähren wie
umgehen also mit den Menschen wie fior
darüber können wir jetzt sprechen mit
Sergej lagodinski er ist für die Grünen
im Europaparlament und auch Russisch
jüdischer Herkunft und mit Roderich
Kiesewetter für die CDU im Bundestag
erst einmal schön guten Abend an sie
beide
schönen Abend schönen guten Abend ja
Herr lagudinski sie haben auch gerade
gemeinsam mit uns Herrn fjordor gehört
wie umgehen mit solchen mit mit diesen
Menschen die jetzt da gerade bei uns
auch sind
da sind menschlich natürlich sehr
tragische Geschichten und während ich
dem
zugehört habe habe ich natürlich an
viele ähnlich ähnlichen Fehler gedacht
es ist aber auch zugleich
muss man betonen dass jeder der sich
politisch verfolgt fühlt
hier in Deutschland einen Asylantrag
stellen kann das bedeutet nicht dass
diese Asylantrag dann auch bewilligt
wird aber das müssen dann die Behörden
und die Gerichte nach dem deutschen und
internationalen recht entscheiden also
insofern gibt es diese Möglichkeit immer
noch und die bleibt da und das ist das
was wir betonen diese Möglichkeit muss
auch europaweit also EU-weit im Wege der
individuellen Asylverfahren offen
bleiben für Menschen die das versuchen
möchten
Herr Kiesewetter wie sehen Sie das
ja guten Abend Herr hoch ich sehe es
insgesamt sehr skeptisch natürlich gilt
das Asylrecht aber Herr lagodinski hat
es ja sehr deutlich gesagt das muss
europaweit abgestimmt werden Deutschland
hat sich sehr klar an die Seite der
Ukraine gestellt wir haben über 1,1
Millionen Menschen aus der Ukraine hier
vorwiegend Frauen und Kinder die an
Männer im Krieg sind und ich halte es
für unverantwortlich dafür zu werben
oder offen zu sein von vornherein
zuzustimmen das russische
mobilisierungsverweigerer nach
Deutschland kommen hier bedarf es einer
europäischen Abstimmung denn wir müssen
uns auch bewusst sein dass dies eine
Sicherheitslücke ist und dass wir hier
uns ein Sicherheitsrisiko ins Land holen
eine europäische Abstimmung würde
bedeuten dass insbesondere die Länder
russische mobilisierungsverweigerer
aufnehmen die
weitaus weniger ukrainische Flüchtlinge
aufgenommen haben
und zudem sollte uns bewusst sein dass
wir bei einer solchen Aufnahme wirklich
die Asylgründe ethnische politische und
religiöse Verfolgung betrachten und auch
mit einbeziehen müssen das über sieben
Monate diese Menschen zu Hause waren
weil nicht ethnische Russen kämpfen
mussten und jetzt wo die ethnischen
Russen einberufen werden nachdem die
Minderheiten das furchtbare
kriegshhandwerk leisten mussten das Land
verlassen das ist unethisch und hier
sind wir nicht unbedingt als erste
aufgerufen aufzunehmen
dann bleiben wir ganz kurz bei dem Punkt
sie sprechen von einer europäisch
abgestimmten Lösung jetzt ist aber so
das haben wir auch im Beitrag gesehen
dass einige baltische Staaten auch Polen
die Grenzen geschlossen haben aus Angst
davor das ist eben jetzt unter diesen
Menschen immer noch Menschen gibt die
Kremel Kreml treu waren und auch noch
sind sehen Sie diese Gefahr auch wenn ja
warum
ja selbstverständlich und ich habe
volles Verständnis nicht nur für die
Aussagen der litauischen Präsidenten
sondern für das Sicherheitsbedürfnis der
mittelosteuropäischen Staaten und auch
der skandinavischen Staaten Deutschland
hat hier eine Scharnierfunktion und es
wäre gut wenn die Bundesregierung hier
wie soll ich sagen eine Art
Verhandlungsposition aufnimmt um dafür
sich einzusetzen das in anderen
europäischen Ländern weit westlicher
Portugal Spanien mitgeholfen wird
russische mobilisierungsverweiger
aufzunehmen aber wir sehen auch das
Putin ein Hybriden Krieg gegen Europa
führt wir sind Kriegsziel aber nicht
Kriegspartei und deswegen wird er auch
Menschen bei uns einschleusen wollen die
hier Sonderaufgaben durchführen wir
müssen hier mit daran denken dass
Russland die volle Klaviatur als Krieges
gegen uns einsetzen wird und dazu gehört
auch eine Bedrohung durch Einsendung von
Menschen die eben sehr Putin treu sind
mit einem besonderen Auftrag
dann leite ich doch diese Frage auch
noch mal an Sie weiter sehen Sie diese
Bedrohung diese Gefahr auch und können
Sie die Ängste verstehen ja
selbstverständlich und ich war auch
einer der ersten der sofort gesagt hat
dass wir zum Beispiel nicht ein groß
angelegtes Programm haben sollen wo wir
Menschen nur weil sie unter die
Kategorie der potenziellen
Kriegs dienenden ja den Reservisten hier
einfach auch automatisch ein pauschal
aufnehmen in dem Sinne verstehe ich
absolut auch die Sorgen der
Anrainerstaaten in Russland
das ist eine Selbstverständlichkeit und
ja das sage ich auch vielen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von mir die dann sagen und
vergleichen mit der Situation der
Kriegsdienst Verweigerer zum Beispiel
aus Syrien oder aus anderen Ländern wo
diese Kriegsgründe also
einberufungsgründer als Asylgründe auch
angesehen werden wir müssen natürlich
die Situation anders hier betrachten
denn ob wir es wollen oder nicht muss
man betrachtet uns als Gegner das hört
man aus allen Reden von Putin heraus
trotzdem muss ich sagen dass solche
sicherheitsängste nicht den
Rechtszustand aufheben bei dem wir sind
und insofern erlaube ich mir Herrn
kieserwetter auch zu widersprechen wenn
Menschen Asyl hier beantragen dann
werden natürlich unter nach
Sicherheitschecks und
Sicherheitsüberprüfung aber auch
Kriegsdienstverweigerung ist
ein anerkannter Grund zumindest gilt da
einer widerlegbarer Vermutung dass dies
aus politischen Gründen passiert das
können die Behörden und die Gerichte
dann widerlegen also in jedem Fall
müsste dann individuell entschieden
werden wo ich auch seiner Meinung bin
wiederum ist dass wir jetzt keinen
großangelegtes Programm für
Kriegsdienstverweigerer brauchen wir
sollen lieber das Programm ausweiten was
wir jetzt schon haben das sind die
humanitären visas für die Dissidenten
für diejenigen die seit Monaten oder
vielleicht sogar seit Jahren gegen Putin
offen protestiert haben und die wir
jetzt in gerade in diese Situation nach
Deutschland in die EU holen müssen weil
sie gegen diesen Krieg immer schon waren
Hella gutinski über die Lösungen und
perspektionen
diese Wetter wollen Sie direkt erwidern
weil ich hätte jetzt gesagt über die
Lösungen sprechen wir gleich bleiben wir
vielleicht bei dem Punkt der Herr den
Herr lagodinski angesprochen hat das
Asylrecht da kommt auch von user-chat
nach Noah einen Kommentar an Sie Herr
Kiesewetter geht in der ähnliche
Richtung Asylrecht gilt auch dann wenn
es keine europäische Abstimmung gibt es
ist ein Gesetz und er schreibt es bewegt
ihn gerade sehr es regt ihn auf es ist
ein Gesetz keine moralfrage sondern eben
ein Gesetz was sagen sie zu dem Punkt
ja das ist zwar richtig aber wir sollten
sehr vorsichtig sein wer sich dann bei
uns bewirkt und mit welchen Gründen und
müssen äußert sorgfältig das prüfen wir
haben eines der liberalsten Asylgesetze
weltweit erst recht in Europa das
verteidige ich auch ich war auch einer
derjenigen der 2015 ganz eindeutig für
die Aufnahme von über eine Million
Flüchtlingen aus Syrien gestimmt hat
auch in intensiver Unterstützung damals
als Präsident des Reservistenverbandes
wo wir hunderte Reservisten dafür
eingesetzt haben dafür stehe ich aber
ich sage auch sehr klar wir sind
Kriegsziel und wir wissen auch sehr
genau dass Russland die es ausnutzen
kann deswegen muss eine umfangreiche
Sicherheitsüberprüfung erfolgen ich
möchte nicht so weit gehen wie der
frühere Botschafter Ischinger der eine
schriftliche Erklärung abverlangte denn
die hat kein rechtlichen wert und wir
sollten unser Recht dann nicht ausnutzen
lassen sondern intensiv prüfen zudem
gilt auch der erste einreiseort also
insofern könnte auch der Asylantrag in
Finnland gestellt werden und muss nicht
in Deutschland gestellt werden da gilt
wiederum Schengen und Dublin und es muss
dann nicht in Deutschland gestellt
werden er kann genauso gut Asyl in
Finnland beantragen und diese Frage muss
ich dann auch fjor der Architekt
gefallen lassen aber wie können denn
diese Herr Kiesewetter diese
individuellen Kontrollen die Sie
ansprechen dann genau aussehen also
dieser Spagat zwischen humanitärer Hilfe
aber doch sorgfältiger Prüfung den sie
ansprechen haben sie dann eine Lösung
wie geht es um ein klares politisches
Signal Deutschlands in Richtung der
Ukraine dass wir an der Seite der
Ukraine stehen und in Richtung Russland
dass wir kein System change wollen aber
auch die russischen Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ermutigen die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger der Russischen Föderation dass
sie Rückhalt haben bei uns und dass sie
mithelfen ihr Land zu einem besseren zu
machen dass dieser furchtbare
völkerrechtswidrige Krieg mit
furchtbaren Kriegsverbrechen beendet
wird und wir sollten uns in Deutschland
nicht auf eine Scheindiskussion Asyl
einlassen sondern alles tun dass dieser
Krieg durch eine massive Unterstützung
der Ukraine da bin ich ganz auf der
Seite von Herrn lagodinski und etlichen
anderen grünen durch eine massive
Unterstützung so rasch wie möglich
beendet wird dass die Ukraine in ihrer
Souveränität in den Grenzen zumindest
vom Januar dieses Jahres wieder
hergestellt wird und es ist schon
verwunderlich wenn Russen sieben Monate
nach Kriegsbeginn wenn dann die
Mobilisierung auch sie selbst betrifft
wo vorher vorwiegend nicht ethn großen
kämpfen mussten aus Dagestan aus
boriatien aus Tschetschenien das ist
jetzt die selbst berührt sie plötzlich
erkennen dass sie diesen Krieg nicht
unterstützen es ist ja gut wenn sie den
Krieg nicht unterstützen aber ich rate
zur Vorsicht und dass wir nicht das
Prinzip unseres Asylrechts über die
Sicherheitsbedenken stellen so dass wir
sehr sorgfältig und abgewogen die
Prüfungen vornehmen und zugleich auch
dafür schauen ob dann anerkannte
Asylbewerber nicht außerhalb
Deutschlands Aufnahme finden sei es in
Spanien oder in Portugal darüber kann
man dann reden Herr lagodinski sie
sitzen für die Grünen auch im
Europaparlament sie waren vor wenigen
Tagen auch in Straßburg bei den
Abstimmungen zu genau diesen dieser
Thematik die EU empfiehlt ja strengere
Kontrollen überlässt aber die
Entscheidung generell den einzelnen
Mitgliedsstaaten wie könnte für Sie
diese Lösung aussehen zwischen
individuellen humanitären Einzelfällen
wie es bei Fjodor jetzt durchklingt
durchgeklungen ist den wir gehört haben
aber eben doch der Prüfung was für
Menschen da gerade sind
ich finde dass wir hier nicht mit
zweierlei Maß messen sollten ich bin der
Meinung dass wir zum Beispiel die
sogenannten pushbacks wie sie wir sie im
Mittelmeer erleben wo eben Griechenland
oder anderer
Staaten im Süden Menschen praktisch ins
Wasser zurück pushen damit sie es nicht
schaffen einen Antrag Asylantrag zu
stellen und genau das verurteilen wir
und das müssen wir auch im Falle unserer
baltischen Freundinnen und Freunde
genauso kritisch sehen also es muss
einen Weg einen Weg gefunden werden für
Menschen die werden jetzt vielleicht
auch nicht so viele mehr sein die
individuell
einen Antrag stellen möchten auch in den
baltischen Staaten dass sie diesen
Antrag stellen können ein anderer ein
Ausweg wäre oder einer ein Teillösung
wäre zum Beispiel eine Umverteilung das
was Herr Kiesewetter auch jetzt erwähnt
hat und Verteilung auf andere Staaten
damit eben nicht die baltischen Partner
am meisten betroffen sind von diesem
diesen Menschen von diesen billigen
antragswilligen das ist aber nicht
einfach ich habe diese Resolutionen
verhandelt für die Grünen jetzt diese
Woche in Straßburg und habe ihn genau
diesen Vorschlag auch gemacht dass wir
entlasten in dieser Staaten
osteuropäischen Staaten und die
Vertreterinnen dieser Staaten haben just
genau gesagt nein danke wollen wir nicht
weil sie das als Präsident Fall
sehen
Präsident für zukünftige Situationen mit
Menschen aus anderen Ländern wo sie
vielleicht auch aufnehmen müssten also
wir sind hier im Bereich des
migrationsrechts was die EU für die EU
immer schon ein problematisches genau
und gerade wegen des Widerstands von
vielen osteuropäischen Staaten die eben
nicht einer Liberalisierung in diesem
Gebiet wollen was wir aber in dieser
Resolution festgeschrieben
haben ist dass wir anderen Drittstaaten
denn Georgien
Armenien
Kasachstan Staaten die sehr viele solche
Menschen aufgenommen haben also
Kriegsdienstverweigerer dass wir denen
massiv unter die Arme greifen und
insbesondere finanziell unterstützen
diese Menschen würdevoll unterzubringen
was ich aber jetzt immer noch nicht ganz
konkret verstanden habe also wir haben
die Situation aber wir haben offenbar
noch keine klare individuelle Lösung
gefunden vielleicht können sie beide
mich dann noch mal mit mit hinnehmen wie
könnte denn eine Prüfung im Einzelfall
dann aussehen vielleicht Herr der
lagodinski noch mal
also die Prüfung einer ganz normale
Prüfung eines Asylantrags das haben wir
jetzt auch mit einigen übrigens das ist
nicht ein neues Phänomen viele
Dissidenten also wirklich Putin Gegner
sind mit Schengen Visa zu Beginn des
Krieges nach Deutschland oder in die EU
gekommen und sie sind mit diesen
Schengen Visa auch hier gewissermaßen
erstmal hängen geblieben und einige von
denen mussten dann Asylantrag stellen
dann müssen Sie nachweisen dass sie eben
politische Gründe haben warum sie in die
EU möchten nach dem nach der Besprechung
des Europäischen Gerichtshof ist
eben die Drohung das Risiko eingezogen
zu werden sein in einer Armee es war ein
Fall mit einem syrischen Kriegsdienst
Verweigerer
das ist schon es wird vermutet dass es
ein aus politischen Gründen eben diese
Kriegsdienstverweigerung stattgefunden
hat also die Chancen sind gar nicht so
schlecht
die Behörden und die Gerichte können
eben aber wahrscheinlich auch
nachvollziehen und nachweisen wenn Sie
es mögen dass diese Menschen zum
Beispiel den Krieg vorher gut geheißen
haben zum Beispiel auf sozialen Medien
und in diesem Fall wäre ein politischer
Grund ausgeschlossen
gehen wir noch mal auf die Diskussion in
Deutschland darauf zu sprechen auch
Reaktionen von Politikerinnen und
Politikern sie beide haben wir heute
Abend hier dafür noch mal vielen Dank
auch Teile aus der Bundesregierung haben
sich geäußert das schauen wir uns jetzt
mal gemeinsam an das ist zum einen
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer sie
sagt wer sich dem Regime von Präsident
Wladimir Putin mutig entgegenstellt und
sich deshalb in größte Gefahr begibt der
kann in Deutschland wegen politischer
Verfolgung Asyl beantragen und auch
Bundesjustizminister
Marco Buschmann hat getwittert
anscheinend verlassen viele Russen ihre
Heimat wer putinsweg hast und die
liberale Demokratie liebt der ist uns in
Deutschland herzlich willkommen
#teil-mobil machen also da ein Signal
ein grundsätzliches Jahr Herr
Kiesewetter ist das aus Sicht der CDU
ein gutes Signal oder ist die
Bundesregierung da etwas zu forschen aus
ihrer Sicht
nun das ist ja gewesen vor etwas mehr
als einer Woche und die Bundesregierung
hat sich ja selbst korrigiert und ist da
etwas zurückhaltender geworden ich
wünschte mir dass die Bundesregierung
dieses Scharnierfunktion oder Führung
übernimmt und versucht auf die
baltischen und polnischen Staaten
einzuwirken auch die Zahlen zu prüfen
die es dort betrifft und mitzuhelfen das
entsprechende Asylbewerber woanders
unterkommen und der lagodinski hat ja
auch einen Weg aufgezeigt was
Drittstaaten angeht wie Armenien wie
auch Griechenland Entschuldigung wie wie
auch Georgien und ich möchte hier ganz
offen auch Zypern erwähnen ein Land das
in der Vergangenheit sehr
russlandfreundlich und Russland offen
war und Staatsbürgerschaften für
Geldsummen vergeben hat dorthin sind
keine Ukrainer geflüchtet das wären
Möglichkeiten so sehr das Vorgehen
Zypern seiner Zeit zu verurteilen war
aber ich möchte trotzdem dass wir in
Deutschland mit allergrößter vorsicht
damit umgehen denn es wäre schlimm wenn
wenn ihr hier eine zusätzliche Spaltung
in der Gesellschaft bekommen wenn wir
Zehntausende von
mobilisierungsverweigerungen aufnehmen
die ersten Monate nach Kriegsbeginn ihr
Gewissen entdeckt haben ganz anders
sieht es aus mit den über 400.000 die
vorwiegend jungen Menschen die bereits
zu Kriegsbeginn Russland verlassen haben
die sind nach Georgien gegangen in die
Türkei nach Skandinavien und Kanada hier
kann ich mir sehr gut die Unterstützung
vorstellen das sind zwar auch nicht
alles Systemgegner aber sie haben sehr
früh erkannt dass das ein
völkerrechtswidriger Krieg ist und
deswegen brauchen wir eine vernünftige
Abwägungsentscheidung das einfach über
Twitter mit Euphorie zu leisten ist für
mich keine vernünftige Politik
da spricht Herr Kiesewetter auch die
Sichtweise an die die sie vorhin
thematisiert haben also die Programme
für eben auch junge Russen dann da das
weiter zu unterstützen wie könnten diese
Programme dann aussehen
wir haben ja jetzt schon humanitäre Visa
das ist übrigens eine Seltenheit in der
EU das Europäische Parlament hat schon
2018 verlangt dass die EU also alle
Mitgliedstaaten humanitäre Visa vergeben
da sind Visa die man am Wohnort quasi
beantragen kann und dadurch eben nicht
nach Dublin 2 das was Herr Kiesewetter
auch erwähnte also nicht nach unserem
europäischen Asylrecht stecken bleibt im
ersten Land wo sie landen also wo sie
die Grenze
überqueren können das kann dann
Deutschland eben vergeben und wir haben
gesehen dass das Innenministerium in
Zusammenarbeit mit dem Auswärtigen Amt
diesen Prozess auch jetzt gestaltet ich
kenne diesen Prozess da werden Menschen
die wirklich
nachweislich und glaubwürdigerweise
gegen das Regime immer schon gekämpft
haben oder jetzt gegen den Krieg kämpfen
werden dann mit einem mit einem
einreiserecht nach Deutschland
ausgestattet nach
§ 22 sogenannte
Paragraph für humanitäre Ausnahmen man
könnte und man sollte dies ausweiten
dafür brauchen wir mehr Ressourcen es
bindet sehr viel diplomatisches Personal
und dafür brauchen wir auch
Sicherheitschecks die werden auch bei
diesen Menschen durchgeführt es wäre gut
und ratsam wenn wir das Ausweiten aber
da muss ich auch ein käsewetter ein
bisschen Realitätscheck dazu sozusagen
mitgeben nach
§ 22 wie er wahrscheinlich weiß werden
wir nicht einfach so
Bürgerinnen und Bürger auch wenn sie
jung sind oder auch wenn Sie früher zu
Beginn des Krieges das Land verlassen
haben aufnehmen können das ist rechtlich
nicht möglich es ist ein notwendig dass
es da nachweislich ein Bezug zu
Deutschland aber auch eben eine
politische Haltung gegeben hat die für
diese Menschen dann eben ein Risiko
darstellt und für uns ein nationales
Interesse darstellt dass wir diese
Menschen aufnehmen also ich glaube es
wird nicht so einfach sein Menschen die
auch zu Beginn des Krieges das Land
verlassen haben einfach so ohne weitere
Umstände in Deutschland aufzunehmen
jedenfalls nach nicht nach diesem Wege
aber es gibt andere Wege Menschen können
hier auch
arbeitsarbeit beantragen Arbeitsstellen
finden auch als Freiberufler gibt es
sehr viele gerade aus Russland die ich
hier dann bleiben also es gibt
verschiedene Wege die sollten wir
ausweiten und vielleicht auch
großzügiger sein in der Beurteilung der
Lage
das Innenministerium das hat uns heute
auch noch einmal frisch bestätigt und
geschrieben ich zitiere dass Menschen
die aus Russland fliehen sich Putins
Regime mutig entgegenstellen und deshalb
in größte Gefahr begeben die können im
Einzelfall Asyl beantragen was aber auch
in der Antwort war dass ein weiteres
Zitat aufgrund der stark eingeschränkten
Möglichkeiten aus Russland nach
Deutschland zu reisen gehen wir von
wenigen Fällen aktuell aus und genau
diese Frage nach Zahlen nach Fällen die
stellt sich auch bei uns im Chat von
Virus BLN BLN das kommt bei Youtube gibt
es eigentlich schon Zahlen Schätzungen
wie viele Russen seit der Teil mobil
machen in Deutschland eingereist sind
gibt es dazu was
also wenn wenn ich vielleicht darauf
antworten ich habe keine Zeit ja auch
auch ich habe keine Zeit wir haben
Zahlen zu den humanitären Fällen also im
Rahmen des humanitären Programms das was
ich vorher erwähnt habe also nicht
diejenigen die mit Schengen Visa nach
Deutschland gekommen sind seit Beginn
des Krieges sondern die wirklich dieses
humanitäre Visum bekommen haben und das
ist ungefähr ein bisschen weniger als
500 Leute insgesamt in diesen Monaten
denen wurde so ein Visum genehmigt
hinsichtlich der Menschen die Russland
verlassen da gibt es verschiedene Zahlen
jetzt im Zuge der Mobilisierung gab es
Schätzungen von 300 bis 500.000 die
insgesamt in Richtung baltische Staaten
Kasachstan Georgien bisher ausgereist
sind aber für Deutschland kenne ich
keine Zahlen
dann blicken wir vielleicht zum Schluss
auch noch mal
auf einen anderen Punkt auf eine andere
Betrachtungsweise seit dem Putin die
teilmobil machen ausgerufen hat gibt es
nicht nur jetzt Menschen die sagen das
wollen wir nicht wir wollen fliehen wir
wollen raus wir wollen das nicht
mitmachen sondern es gibt auch weitere
Proteste dagegen innerhalb Russlands
es gibt Menschen die in Armut leben die
einberufen werden und die auch gesagt
haben das haben wir gesehen auch in
einer Dokumentation auf unserem
Youtube-Kanal dass sie teilweise gar
nicht wissen warum sie einberufen werden
andere sagen einfach wir müssen weil wir
einberufen wurden und weil wir auch zu
Armen sind weil wir uns was dazu
verdienen wollen Arbeit generell es gibt
Menschen die sagen nein wollen wir nicht
und die dagegen protestieren Herr
Kiesewetter erste Frage da an sie sehen
sie da dass da was bröckelt auch
innerhalb der Bevölkerung gegen Putin
gegen das Regime
und Putin hat den Krieg ja begonnen oder
die Kriegsvorbereitung begonnen in dem
Jahr wo nahwalne
zurückgereist ist bevor er ins Gefängnis
kam jedes Wochenende zehntausende
Menschen auf die Straße gegangen sind
tausende festgesetzt wurden im selben
Jahr 2019 wo auch hunderttausende in
Weißrussland auf die Straße ging und
seither hat Putin ein sehr repressives
weiterhin gehend repressives System
entwickelt Herr lagodinski kennt das
viel intensiver als ich und dieses
repressive System daran scheitert jede
Zivilcourage deswegen ist es umso höher
einzuschätzen wenn sich Bürgermeister
die er auf Druck ihrer Bevölkerung auch
handeln um die Absetzung von Putin
bemühen das ist ja fast schon Droll
Digger und auf der anderen Seite dass
wir eine ganze Reihe von Menschen mit
denen auch ich zusammengearbeitet habe
wie chromiko oder cortonew-
gestellt wurde der Enkel des früheren
Außenministers also da tut sich etwas
aber der Druck die Putin mit seiner
Leibgarde aber auch mit der Nation und
mit seinem System ausübt der ist immer
noch sehr groß dazu kommt das
levada-institut ist ein Unabhängigkeit
wir anerkennen hat festgestellt dass
noch im September über 70 Prozent der
Bevölkerung hinter diesem
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg stehen und
auch die spezialoperationen unterstützen
wenn dann müssen wir geduldig sein
unsere Sanktionen wirken die
Automobilindustrie Islam gelegt die
Konsumgüterindustrie gibt die Chips für
Kampfpanzer her und vieles andere mehr
wir müssen geduldig sein die Sanktionen
wirken aber das ist genau die Naht auf
die Putin geht indem er glaubt dass wir
in unserer aus seiner Sicht Dekadenz
nicht in der Lage sind den Winter zu
überstehen ohne Volksaufstände und
deshalb ist auch unser Punkt deswegen
bin ich Ihnen auch mit dieser Sendung so
dankbar dass unsere Bevölkerung die
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer vorbereitet
werden dass wir vor zwei oder drei
Jahren harten Jahren stehen auf die wir
uns einstellen müssen und wenn wir diese
Geduld haben wird auch die Kraft in
Russland zunehmen sich von diesem System
zu befreien aber das ist Sache der
Russinnen und Russen und nicht unsere
Aufgabe denn Russland muss sein System
annehmen wenn es es erneuern will das
muss aus eigener Kraft kommen
heller godinski wie ist Ihre Antwort zu
diesem Punkt
ich glaube Putin hat sich mit dieser
Mobilisierung keinen Gefallen getan das
war eine Notlösung das war eine
Verzweiflungstat die durch die Erfolge
der ukrainischen Armee und den
miserablen Zustand der russischen Armee
bedingt ist wir werden sehen was das für
Auswirkungen haben wird aber auch hier
wird die Zeit erst zeigen wie die
Bevölkerung darauf reagiert also schon
jetzt gibt es natürlich Aufstände wir
haben es gesehen auch in Pakistan gerade
in kleineren
und eher so in Provinzen von Müttern von
von Frauen die dagegen sind
bald werden Menschen zurückkehren leider
tragischerweise entweder mit
Behinderungen mit Verwundungen oder
als Leichen
das wird für sehr viel
Unruhe Ernüchterung eine tragische
Ernüchterung in der russischen
Bevölkerung sorgen wir dass in also die
die Leute haben das in der Sowjetunion
erlebt während des Afghanistan Krieges
und dieser Krieg ist viel viel blutiger
und viel schlimmer als Afghanistan Krieg
weil es ist auch sehr schwer zu erklären
warum es diesen Krieg überhaupt geben
muss
insofern glaube ich schon dass hier
eben Putin noch mal sich verkalkuliert
hat wir werden aber sehen wie lange es
dauert bis die Bevölkerung das auch so
sieht und bis das hören wir gerade heute
im Umfeld von Putin eben auch einer
Ernüchterung und vielleicht auch
Widerspruch kommt
danke an sie beide für den Ausblick
hinten raus hier bei ZDF heute live Säge
lagodinski war das und Roderich
Kiesewetter herzlichen Dank für die
differenzierte Diskussion für ihre
Einschätzung und ihre Zeit
danke auch dass ihr wieder Gast in
unserem Stream gewesen seid zur Frage
fluchtstadt Kampfeinsatz sollte
Deutschland russischen Kriegsdienst
Verweigerern und Deserteuren Asyl
gewähren darüber haben wir gesprochen
darüber wird sehr sehr wahrscheinlich
auch in der nächsten Zeit diskutiert
werden dann gerne auch wieder mit euch
hier bei ZDF heute live bis dahin
macht's gut noch einen schönen Abend
ciao